Speaker 1: All right. Let's go back
to the phone lines and hear from a few
more people. We don't really use the
phone lines anymore. We use Discord,
which you can find at David Pakman dot com
slash discord that is the place to find it and
chat with me. Let's go to Tyler from
Columbia. Is that Columbia, South Carolina?
Tyler from Columbia on the air.
Speaker 5: Hey, David, sorry, it's
Tyler from Columbus, Ohio.
Speaker 1: Oh, Columbus,
Ohio. Got it. You're on the air.
Speaker 5: Well, thanks for having me,
I'm a longtime listener, a big fan of the
show. Thank you. I guess my first question is.
I don't really think, given the polling trajectory
with, you know, Kamala Harris and Joe Biden,
I think we would almost assuredly
lose if we run either of them in 2024.
I think by instinct, you ought to run, I don't
think he's going to seek reelection and I think,
you know, Kamala Harris is not a good choice. So
who do you think if it were up to you, who would
you pick to be the Democratic nominee in 2024?
Speaker 1: You know, I have no
answer because at this
Speaker 2: point, there is
Speaker 1: really nobody in the Democratic
Party that I'm genuinely excited about and
that I see. And when I say excited, I mean, not
only do I like them on policy, but that I also
believe that they are sort
Speaker 2: of like a political
Speaker 1: superstar of sorts. You know,
there was something like him or hate him.
There was something about Bill Clinton when he
entered the national scene where it was like,
This guy is a political superstar different than
you agree with him on every policy or anything
like that. But it was just he had a certain
something. Barack Obama has a certain something.
I don't think Joe Biden really has it, but I think
the circumstances still allowed him to win. And I
am with you. I think that
Speaker 2: particularly
Speaker 1: if Trump is the nominee, but even if
it's someone like Ron DeSantis who seems right,
you know, we are looking now
seems like the other possible guy.
Speaker 2: I don't know that Biden
Speaker 1: wins
Speaker 2: reelection, and I think if
Speaker 1: he steps back and there's
sort of a coronation for Kamala Harris and she's
kind of just handed the nomination, I don't think
she beats Trump or DeSantis, so I am extremely
concerned. What I'm trying to do, though, is
say, let's get through the midterms
Speaker 2: first, because
Speaker 1: what happens in the midterms is going
Speaker 2: to really
Speaker 1: determine the context
in which 2024 takes place. But
I am as worried as you are right now.
Speaker 5: Do you think there is a scenario
in which Democrats hold the House?
Speaker 1: I think it's possible,
but unlikely. I think we have to
fight for it, right? I don't know what
what number I would attached to it. I would
maybe call it 10 or 15 percent, but that's high.
Speaker 2: The stakes are
Speaker 1: so big that you've got to fight. If
you have got a 10 percent shot, you got to fight
for that. I agree. Thanks. All right, thank you
so much for the call. Very much. Appreciate
it. I don't want to. I'm not trying to be
unnecessarily pessimistic. I'm just kind of
explaining explaining it the way I see it,
you know? Let's go next to next to Jeff
from Dallas, Texas. Jeff, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: Wow, it literally
sounds like what you're
Speaker 1: not actually underwater, are you?
Speaker 4: No, I was running. Oh my
Speaker 1: God. OK, what's going on?
Speaker 4: Oh, sorry, I mean, I was
trying to get away. Yes. So first off, love
the show. It's my first time calling it, so
I'm very excited to chat with you. Thank you. So
sorry, I'm a little nervous. I've never done this
before. Now you're doing great. OK. Oh, I kind
of. You know, there's been more talk about the.
Speaker 1: All right, unfortunately, Jeff,
your service is so bad, we can't hear you,
you're going in and out, so we will have to try
to make the connection at some point in the future